so we have an interesting shape right
over here the base is a rectangular
prism in the dimensions of that
rectangular prism it's three units I
guess we could say tall four units wide
and then four units long and then on top
of that on top of that we have what you
could call a right pyramid where the the
height of this right pyramid so if you
start at the center of its base right
over here and you go to the top this
height right over here is one unit and
this hasn't been drawn completely the
scale and kind of the perspective skews
it a little bit but our goal here our
goal here is to figure out what is the
length what is the length of one of
these of one of these edges right over
here so either that one or this one
right over here what is that length and
we will call that we will call that X
and so I encourage you to pause this
video and try to think about it on your
own remember this is a right this is a
right pyramid so what that tells us is
is that this red line that is that's a
one unit long it is perpendicular it is
perpendicular to this entire plane it's
perpendicular to the top of the
rectangular of the rectangular prism so
with that in mind I encourage you to
pause the video and see if you can
figure it out and I will give you a hint
you will have to use the Pythagorean
theorem maybe more than once alright so
I assuming you you've at least given it
a shot so let's work through it together
so the key here is to realize well okay
this this point this base right over you
this point right over here it's half way
in this direction half way in this
direction so we can figure out well this
entire this entire length right over
here is length four so halfway this is
going to be I'll write it with
perspective that's going to be two and
that's going to be two just like that
and then the other thing we can figure
out we can figure out what this this
length is going to be
because once again it's half way in that
direction so if this whole thing is to
and we see it right over here this is a
rectangular prism so this length is
going to be the same thing as this
length so this whole thing is to then
each of these this is going to be one
and this is going to be one right over
there well how does that help us well
using that information we should be able
to figure out we should be able to
figure out this length see let me which
I'll keep it in this color - this color
is easy to see we should be able to
figure out this length well why is this
length interesting well if we know that
length that length forms a right
triangle that length and the one are the
two non hypotenuse sides of a right
triangle and then the X would be the
hypotenuse so we could just apply the
Pythagorean theorem so if we can figure
out this we can figure out X so let's do
one step at a time how do we figure out
how do we figure out on oh let me call
this length how do we call that how do
we figure out length a well let's just
take it out and look at it in two
dimensions so if we look at it in two
dimensions if we look at it in two
dimensions it would look something like
this so that's our length a we know that
this length is half of this side right
over here so that's going to be one and
actually let me do it the same colors so
this right over here is the same thing
as this right over here and it is going
to be of length one and then this right
over here is going to be the same as
this right over here
which is going to be of length two and
so we can just use the Pythagorean
theorem here we know that the hypotenuse
squared is going to be equal to 1
squared 1 squared plus 2 squared 1
squared plus 2 squared which of course
is equal to 5 sorry is equal to this 1
plus 4 which is equal to 5 so we could
write a let me do this in the magenta
color we could write a squared is equal
to 5 or we could say that a is equal to
the principal root of 5 so this length
right over here is the square root
of five the principle root of five and
now we can use that information to solve
for X and let's take this right triangle
and it sticks a little bit of
visualization practice to visualize
right but notice this is a right
triangle this this height right here of
length one is perpendicular to this
entire plane so let's see if I can draw
so this so we have this side is the
square root of five and then we have a
height let me do it looks like it's in a
well let's say we're talking about this
height right over here this height right
over here is length one so I'll draw
that that is of length one and we are
trying to figure out X we are trying to
figure out X in orange so we're trying
to figure out we're trying to figure out
this X and once again we know this is a
right triangle this is a right triangle
so we can apply the Pythagorean theorem
again so we will have x squared is equal
to one squared which is just I'll just
write it 1 squared plus square root of
five squared plus square root of five
squared well that gets us x squared is
equal to one plus five right square root
of five squared is just five so one plus
five is equal to six so we get X is
equal to the square root of six and
we're done we figured out the length of
this side right over here